اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه من العربيه
نستعرض ونرصد معكم ابرز المستجدات في
العناوين
التسريبات الامريكيه تكشف المزيد صربيا
رفضت فرض عقوبات على روسيا وبيون يون
تلاعبت بالصواريخ
بعد ضمان تقدمها في بخموت شرق اوكرانيا
روسيا تجسد الغرب باطلاق صاروخ باليستين
متقدم عابر للقارات
الصين تصعد ضد تايوان وتخطط لفرض منطقه
حظر طيران شمال الجزيره لثلاثه ايام خلال
شهر ابريل الجاري
بريطانيا تكشف تسلل جواسيس صينيين عبر
جنسيه ثالثه وتخشى تسلل الجواسيس الروس
عبر الوسيله ذاتها
اهلا بكم معلومات جديده مشاهدينا كشفت
عنها الوثائق الامريكيه المسربه فنحن
نتحدث عن اكثر من خمسين وثيقه ختمت بسري
او سري للغايه اخر ما كشفت عنه التسريبات
يتعلق هذه المره في صربيا الدوله الوحيده
في اوروبا التي رفضت معاقبه روسيا على
اجتياحها لاوكرانيا حيث تقول الوثائق
صربيا وافقت على ارسال الاسلحه الكييف او
قد زودتها بالفعل لكنها رفضت توفير تدريب
القوات الاوكرانيه وفي وثائق اخرى
مشاهدينا كشفت ان كوريا الشماليه عرضت
عددا غير مسبوق من قذائف الصواريخ
الباليستيه العابره للقارات في عرض نظمته
في فبراير وكانت على الارجح تحمل انظمه
غير قابله للتشغيل اي مزيفه الوثيقه تقول
ان الهدف من ذلك هو استعراض ليس الاستعراض
ليس الا تريد من خلاله اثبات ان لديها قوه
صاروخيه اكبر واكثر قدره مما تمتلكها
بالفعل الوثائق السريه اقفلت اروقه
المسؤولين او اقلقتهم في واشنطن حول كيفيه
تسريبها وزير الدفاع الامريكي اكد ان
بلاده ستواصل التحقيق في التسريب حتى تعرف
مصدره وشدد اوستن خلال مؤتمر صحفي على ان
واشنطن تتعامل مع قضيه الوثائق المسربه
بشكل جدي مشيرا الى انه يتواصل مع كبار
القاده العسكريين يوميا للرد على تسريب
الوثائق واوضح وزير الدفاع الامريكي انا
وثائق الفينتاجون يعود تاريخها الى الفتره
من نهايه فبراير وحتى الاول من مارس
من جهته اعتبر مدير وكاله المخابرات
المركزيه الامريكيه ويليامز اعتبر ان
تسريب الوثائق السريه شيء مؤسف للغايه
[موسيقى]
المشكله فيما ذكرته ان تسريب الوثائق
السريه مؤسف للغايه وانت تعلم هذا امر
تاخذ الاداره الامريكيه على محمل الجد
اطلق البنتاجون ووزاره العدل الان تحقيقا
مكثفا للوصول الى حقيقه الامر ليس هناك
الكثير الذي يمكنني اضافته في هذه المرحله
مع استمرار هذا التحقيق
الى اوكرانيا ومعركه الشرق الاوكراني
وتحديدا معركه بخموت تدور معارك ضاريه وصل
مداها بين جانبين في المدينه الى حرب
شوارع المتحدث باسم الدفاع الروسيه ايغور
كونج قال ان قوات فاجنر تمكنت من التقدم
في وسط مدينه بخموت مضيفا انها تدفع الجيش
الاوكراني نحو الجزء الغربي للمدينه واشار
الى ان قواته باتت تسيطر على اكثر من 80%
من مخموت نظريات
تركزت جهود القتال الرئيسيه في منطقه
الوحدات النجوميه التابعه القتال
للاستيلاء على مناطق من الجزء الاوسط من
ودفع العدو الى الضواحي الغربيه في
المنطقه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
ينضم الينا من دنيتك مراسل العربيه رائد
الاغبر اهلا بك معنا رائد اذا لنتحدث عن
المحور الاكثر شده في المعركه على الارض
الا وهو بخموت بطبيعه الحال كيف تدور
المعارك هناك وهل بالفعل هناك
تقدمير كما تتحدث الانباء
صباح الخير فاطمه فعلا هناك يعني تقدم
للقوات الروسيه او قوات فاجنر في وسط
المدينه مدينه باقمت لكن لابد من الاشاره
ان هناك ملفات اخرى ساخنه مثل باخموت لكن
هو باخموت دائما الاكثر اثاره ما زالت
قوات فارغنر تتقدم وتقاتل حرب في حرب
شوارع معارك ضاريه وشرسه بالفعل في وسط
المدينه في منطقه السكك الحديديه لم تنتهي
هذه المعارك ولم تنسحب حتى الان القوات
الاوكرانيه من الوسط الى الناحيه الغربيه
حيث المناطق الاكثر تمركزا للجيش
الاوكراني لكن هناك انباء من السلطات
الاوكرانيه بان لا يستغرب الشعب الاوكراني
اذا افاق على خبر انسحاب القوات
الاوكرانيه لان وضع الجيش الاوكراني في
مدينه باخمت صعب جدا المعارك ليست في
الوسط وحدها حيث يقوم يعني سلاح الجو
الروسي بتغطيه
سماء مدينه باقوى بضرب قواعد للقوات
الاوكرانيه في المنطقتين الجنوبيه
والشرقيه كما ان المنطقه الغربيه تعتبر
الحصن المنيع للقوات الاوكرانيه حيث تصل
الامدادات منطقتين من منطقه او مدينه
شاسوبيار في الغرب من ناحيه قسطنطينه
بالامس حاول جيش الروسي قطع الامدادات من
الطريق الموصل من قسطنطينه الى باقمه لكنه
لم يفلح في هذه
المحاولات فعلا هناك مقاومه شرسه وتدور
معارك ايضا في المحور الشمالي في بلده
اريخابا
الطوق يكتمل اذا استطاع الجيش الروسي من
دخول مدينه بغداد او بلده بغدانا في
المنطقه الغربيه فيكون قد احكم الطوق
وحاصر القوات الاوكرانيه التي تصل اعدادها
الى 15 الف مقاتل داخل مدينه باخموك هناك
هجمه اوكرانيه على مدينه دنيس نحن نتحدث
في نفس المحور مقاطعه
حذرت السلطات هنا المواطنين من التجول في
الشوارع ونصحت اصحاب الاعمال الخاصه بعدم
الذهاب الى اعمالهم كما انها اصدرت بيانات
للموظفين الحكوميين للعمل من بيوتهم تحسبا
من ضربات مرتقبه من قبل الجيش الاوكراني
لابد ان هناك معلومات مرتبطه بالوثائق
السريه او بمعلومات استخباراتيه بان الجيش
الاوكراني سيعود لضرب مدينه دانيتسكو
وبقوه ايضا هناك عوده للجيش الاوكراني في
مناطق بعيده منطقه زبروجي وخرسون المناطق
الجنوبيه هناك حديث عن حشد اوكرانيا كبير
في هذه المنطقه من اجل العوده الى المحطه
النوويه تقول السلطات المحليه في خرسون
بان الجيش الاوكراني يحشد باعداد كبيره من
اجل العود العوده الى المناط طبعا
الجغرافيا للم فاطمه فاطمه خرسون
قريبتين جدا يعني تقع المحطه النوويه ما
بين خرسون وما بين زبروجي لذلك الهدف
الرئيسي للقوات الاوكرانيه هو
المحطه النوويه لان هذه المحطه تقع على
الضفه الجنوبيه من النهر حيث ان الجيش
الروسي انسحب للضفه الشماليه وبقيت المحطه
ليس تحت سيطره الجيش الروسي ويرغب الجيش
الاوكراني باعاده المحطه الى سيطرته شكرا
لك من دنيتك مراسل العربيه رائد الاخبار
على هذه المعلومات
وتزامنا مع التقدم الروسي في معركه بخموت
مشاهدينا اعلنت وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها
اجرت تجربه ناجحه لاطلاق صاروخ باليستي
متقدم عابر للقارات وبحسب وزاره الدفاع
الروسيه اطلق الصاروخ الباليسي بنجاح من
نظام صاروخي ارضي متحرك والهدف من التجربه
هو اختبار معدات قتاليه متطوره لصواريخ
باليستيه من جانبها اكدت الخارجيه الروسيه
انها اخترت واشنطن بعمليات اطلاق الصاروخ
البالستي العابر للقارات من مقاطعه
استراخان جنوبي البلاد تحديدا وقال نائب
وزير الخارجيه الروسي سيرجي رياضكو واشنطن
لديها معلومات عن عمليه اطلاق الصاروخ من
جهه اخرى قال رياضكو بان الوثائق المسربه
مؤخرا من البنزاجون قد تكون خدعه ومحاوله
تضليل لخدمه اهداف اخرى واعرب ايضا عن رفض
روسيا لتقديم او تقييم واشنطن بان الصحفي
ايفانش محتجز ظلما مشيرا الى انه ضبط
متلبسا بالتجسس ويحاكم وفقا للقانون
الروسي
وكانت حذرت وزاره الخارجيه الروسيه من ان
امداد اوكرانيا بصواريخ الدفاعات الجويه
يهدد حركه المرور الجويه المدني عالميا
مشيره الى ان اهميه طرح مساله سلامه حركه
المرور الجويه المدني في العالم بما في
ذلك فوق اوروبا ستظهر قريبا الخارجيه
الروسيه مشاهدينا اكدت ايضا ان اي تكهنات
من الاتحاد الاوروبي بشان حفظ السلام
فضلوا في الحاليه متناقضه للغايه وفي
الوقت الذي لا يبذل فيه الاتحاد جهود نحو
التسويه السياسيه على حد قولها
وكاله رويترز نقلت عن مصدر في حكومه كوريا
الجنوبيه الناسول تعتزم اقراض الولايات
المتحده 500 الف طلقه مدفعيه بدلا من
بيعها وذلك لتقليل احتماليه استخدام قذائف
من كوريا الجنوبيه في الصراع الاوكراني
الروسي
مصادرز افادت ايضا بانهم شحنات ذخيره
المدفعيه الكوريه سيتم تخصيصها لملئ
مخزونات الولايات المتحده بشكل اساسي
نشرتنا مستمره ونتابع فيها
بريطانيا تدرج 11 جهه جديده على قائمه
العقوبات ضد روسيا
احييكم من جديد نتحدث عن تجربه روسيا
لاطلاق الصواريخ الباليستيه العبر للقارات
مشاهدينا وكان هذا الموضوع تحدثنا عنه
وتناولناه قبل الفاصل نعود اليه الان مع
زميلتنا في موسكو مراسله العربيه كاتيا
طعم اهلا بك معنا كاتيا اذا تجربه صاروخيه
بالستيه عابره للقارات تقوم بها روسيا ما
التبريرات التي ربما تقدمها موسكو لهذه
التجربه ولماذا في هذا التوقيت تحديدا
مرحبا فاطمه هذه التجربه طبعا هي ليست
بالاولى التي تقوم بها موسكو
لاختبار انظمه الصواريخ العابره الى
القارات والتي طبعا هي قادره على حمل رؤوس
نوويه بالاضافه الى ذلك طبعا كما تحدثت
وزاره الدفاع الروسيه انها قامت يوم امس
باختبار هذا الصاروخ وهو عبر القارات هو
ارض ارض بداه قد يسال او يصل الى اكثر من
5500 كيلو متر هو قادر على ان يصيب اهداف
في القارات الاخرى طبعا كما تحدث نائب
وزير الدفاع الروسي عفوا نائب وزير
الخارجي الروسي منذ قليل قال ان روسيا
اقنعت باعلام واشنطن عن نيتها اطلاق هذا
وسنتحدث عن ذلك كاتيا ولكن ماذا تريد ماذا
تريد موسكو تحديدا من هذه التجربه يعني هل
هي ربما نبض للغرب
بعد التهديدات بالسلاح النووي التي
شهدناها مؤخرا كاتيا
هي كما تقول موسكو فاطمه بانها تقوم بهذه
الاختبارات فقط الاختبار طبعا اولا هذه
الانظمه قدرتها على اصابه الاهداف كما
قالت يوم امس انها استطاعت اصابه الهدف
والذي كان هو في كذا خزان طبعا هو هذا
ياتي في ظل تزايد التوتر مع الغرب وكما
تقول موسكو وكما تعلمين ان موسكو تقوم
الان ايضا بنشر اسلحه نوويه في بيلاروسيا
على خلفيه ايضا وجود كما تقول بيلاروسيا
تهديدات للبلاد لكل بدولتي الاتحاد روسيا
وبيلاروسيا هناك نشر او كما تحدث الرئيس
الروسي هناك سيكون نشر رئاسي حاله نوويه
تكتيكيه ايضا في بيلاروسيا هذا ردا على
تعزيزات حلف الناتو التي كانت بدات بها
على الحدود مع بيلاروسيا في بولندا
بالاضافه لذلك هذه تاتي في ظل التوترات
وظل في ظل انضمام الى حلف الناتو الذي
شهدناه ايضا مؤخ را كانت روسيا قد قالت
انها ستقوم بزياده
التدريباتها بالاضافه الى زياده وتعزيز
قواتها على الحدود الروسيه شكرا لك من
موسكو مراسله العربيه كاتيا تعمى على هذه
المعلومات
نقلت وكاله رويترز عن اربعه مصادر ان
الصين تخطط لفرض منطقه حظر طيران في شمال
تايوان في الفتره ما بين السادس عشر الى
الثامن عشر من ابريل الجاري وقالت المصادر
ان الحضره سيعطل معلومات الطيران في
المنطقه وان سبب فرض هذه القيود غير واضح
حتى الان في مقاله وزاره الدفاع
التايوانيه ان الحضره الجويه الصيني سيكون
على بعد 85 ميلا بحريا شمال الجزيره
واشارت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه الى ان
اربعه عشره طائره تابعه للقوات الجويه
الصينيه عبرت خلال 24 ساعه الماضيه خط
منتصف عند مضيق تايوان والذي يفصل بشكل
غير رسمي بين الجانبين في حين رصدت وزاره
الدفاع 35 طائره وثماني سفن صينيه حول
الجزيره من جانبها دعت المتحدثه باسم مكتب
شؤون تايوان الصيني
للتوقف فورا عن الاعتماد على الول
الولايات المتحده للسعي الى الاستقلال
وشراء الاسلحه لرفض اعاده التوحيد الصيني
من اجل طمانه شعب تايوان حقا يجب على
اداره الحزب الديمقراطيه التقدمي التوقف
فورا عن الاعتماد على الولايات المتحده
للسعي الى الاستقلال والتوقف فورا عن شراء
الاسلحه لرفض اعاده التوحيد يجب عليها
ايضا التوقف عن التعامل مع القوه الخارجيه
وتقويض السلام والاستقرار في مضيق تايوان
من بكين ينضموا الينا صحفيين نادر رونج
اهلا بك معنا سيد نادر اذا بعد انتهاء
المناورات العسكريه الصينيه والتي حاكت
فيها تطويق الجزيره بالكامل لماذا تقوم
الان بكين بالنظر في خطه حظر طيران فوق
تايوان
اهلا ومرحبا بكم
يعني حاليا هنا المصادر الوسائل علم سوريا
الرسميه لم تشير الى يعني فرط الحظر الجوي
ولكن
اريد ان اقول هو
[موسيقى]
لا يتجهزوا من الاراضي الصينيه فاي يعني
انشطه الصينيه فوق هذه المنطقه فهي يعني
هل من شؤون الداخليه الصينيه فلا يحق لاي
دوله اخرى التداخل فيها
ولذلك يعني
حاليا لا توجد المصادر الرسميه واكد ذلك
ولكن مصادر رسميه تؤكد ذلك السيد نادر
ولكن وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه علقت بان
حضر الطيران الصيني متعلق بنشاطات ربما
فضائيه صينيه واطلاق قمر صناعي ما صحه هذه
الاقوال ايضا
انا شخصيا بحثت في المواقع الرسميه وكل
الوصيه على الداخله بالروسينيه الرئيسي
فلا يوجد كما قلت
المصادر تؤكد رسميه تؤكد على ذلك ولكن كما
قلت يعني
اراضي الصينيه ماذا تخطط الصين سيدنا نادر
يعني لا دخان بلا نار الى ماذا تخطط الصين
اعتقد هو ايضا
يعني اشاره تحضيريه
الانفصاليين في تايلان وكذلك القوه
الداعمه لها من الخارج كمال نعلم
بالروسينيورايسي في استعداد تهمه
للردع الاي يعني تدخلات العسكريه محتمله
من القوات الامريكيه واليابانيه للشؤون
الداخليه الصينيه
ويعني الجيش التحرير الشعبي الصيني في كل
كل يوم في تدريبات لردع على ذلك طيب
وشاهدنا هذا الرد ورسائل واضحه من الصين
بعد المناورات العسكريه الاخيره ولكن ما
ان تم ما ان صحت هذه الانباء نعلم بانك
تقول ان لا انباء رسميه حتى الان حول حظر
الطيران ولكن ما ان صحت هذه الانباء لماذا
قد تقدم الصين على ذلك ماذا يمكن ان
تستفيد من حظر الطيران هذا من رسائل التي
يمكن ان توجهها عبر حظر الطيران فوق
تايوان
اولا هي يعني تعبير عن قد
اي التدخلات العسكريه المحتمله من الخارج
وثم كذلك هي محاكاه
القتال الميداني لقطع يعني امدادات الطاقه
والاسلحه وكذلك الطريق قطعه طريق الهروب
للانفصاليين في تايلاند
لتنفيس المحيمات اعادات التوحيد الكامل
للبلاد فاذا استمرت
السلطه في تايلاند يعني
الطريقاتهم لرفض التوحيد باستخدام القوه
الجيش التحرير الشعبي الصيني الذي يعني
حلول التدابير لتنفيذ مهمه التوحيد واضح
شكرا لك من بكين الصحفي نادر
مخاوف تتعلق بالامن القومي اثارها دخول
مواطنين صينيين الى بريطانيا من خلال
الحصول على جنسيه دوله ثالثه وذلك حسبما
كشفت صحيفه التايمز البريطانيه حيث حذر
جهاز الاستخبارات البريطاني من ان جواسيس
الصينيين يتسللون الى بريطانيا بالحصول
على جنسيه من دوله اخرى عن طريق الاستثمار
او دفع مبلغ صغير نسبيا من المال في
البلاد وقدم الجهاز الاستخباراتي
البريطاني ادله على دخول مواطنين من دول
وصفها بالمعاديه بما في ذلك الصين لكن
بريطانيا يقلقها الان ايضا ان يستخدم
الجواسيس الروس هذه الطريقه لتسلل الى
المملكه المتحده وفي غضون ذلك ادرجت
بريطانيا 11 جهه جديده على قائمه العقوبات
ضد روسيا واكدت الخارجيه البريطانيه ان
العقوبات تستهدف الكيانات التي تدير
الصناعات الرئيسيه للرئيس بوتين وحظر
تصدير كل شيء يتبين
ان روسيا تستخدمه في ساحه المعركه وكانت
جمدت بريطانيا ايضا اصول مجموعه من
المسؤولين الروس والشركات الروسيه
واستهدفتهم في العام الماضي في مسعى لشل
اقتصاد موسكو والحد من قدراتها فاصل ونعود
التسريبات الامريكيه تكشف المزيد صربيا
رفضت فرض عقوبات على روسيا وبيونغيانج
تلاعبت بالصواريخ
بعد ضمان تقدمها في بخموت شرق اوكرانيا
روسيا تجس نبض الغرب باطلاق صاروخ
باليستين متقدم عابر للقارات
الصين تصاعد ضد تايوان وتخطط لفرض منطقه
حظر طيران شمال الجزيره لثلاثه ايام خلال
شهر ابريل الجاري
وبريطانيا تكشف تسلل جواسيس الصينيين عبر
جنسيه ثالثه وتخشى تسلل الجواسيس الروس
عبر الوسيله ذاتها
احييكم من جديد اكد المجلس العسكري في
ميانمار شنغارات جويه على قريه في وسط
البلاد اودت بحياه نحو 100 شخص بحسب
تقارير محليه وقال المتحدث باسم المجلس
العسكري ان القصف استهدف جماعه مناهضه
وصفها بالارهابيه كما اقر بسقوط ضحايا
مدنيين وقال عضو في قوات الدفاع الشعبي في
ميانمار ان طائرات مقاتله قصفت حفل افتتاح
لمكتبها المحلي اما في الهند اعلن الجيش
الهندي ان حادث اطلاق نار وقع في ساعه
مبكره من اليوم الاربعاء في محطه بثيندا
العسكريه في ولايه البنجاب الحدوديه شمال
الهند واسفر عن مقتل اربعه اشخاص وبحسب
الجيش عمليات البحث الجاريه وتم اغلاق
المنطقه ووفق مصدر في وزاره الدفاع
لرويتورز فان عددا غير معلوم من مطلق
النار ما زال طريقا في المحطه العسكريه
يوصل اليوم الاف الاطباء في المملكه
المتحده يمثلون نصف اطباء القطاع العام
يواصلون اضرابا مدته اربعه ايام للمطالبه
باجور افضل في خضم ازمه غلاء المعيشه ووصف
القائمون على النظام الصحي التعبئه بانها
الاشد تاثيرا في تاريخ الخدمات الصحيه في
بريطانيا داعينا البريطانيين الى تجنب
التصرفات الخطره لان النظام الصحي غير
قادر على توفير العنايه اللازمه
شيرين مواطنه بريطانيه تلقت رساله هذا
الصباح من خدمه الصحه الوطنيه تبلغها
بتاجيل موعدها حتى يوليو المقبل ما يعني
انها ستضطر الى تحمل الم تعاني منه منذ
سنوات في عمودها الفقري املها الا يتسبب
الانتظار بتفاقم وضعها الصحي
تلقيت رساله هذا الصباح تبلغني ان موعدي
تاجل حتى نهايه يوليو ما يعني اني ساتحمل
الالم لبضعه اشهر اخرى وقد تزداد المشكله
سوءا الغاء موعد شيرين من ضمن 350 الف
موعد طبي ملغى او مؤجل لاشخاص سيتاثرون
بالاضات المستمره حتى عطله نهايه الاسبوع
المطالب رفع الاجور بنسبه 35% نسبه قالت
النقابات انها تاخذ بالاعتبار السنوات
الخمسه عشره الاخيره التي لم تشهد زياده
عادله نسبه ترفضها الحكومه وترى انها غير
واقعيه
[موسيقى]
التقينا بالسيد باركلي مرتين حتى الان في
المره الاولى لم يكن لديه اي تفويض
لمناقشه الاجور اما المره الثانيه التي
التقينا به لم يقدم لنا عرضا بل وخرج من
المفاوضات
الهدف بالنسبه للاطباء ليس انيا وانما في
طياته بعد نظر قبل انهيار القطاع الصحي
بالكامل اذا ظل كما هو الان
هذه الاضرابات ضروريه لتحسين الوضع الصحي
على الرغم من انها تتسبب بازمه على المدى
القصير لكن امل حقا ان يفهم المرضى اننا
نفعل ذلك ليس فقط من اجلنا ولكن ايضا من
اجلهم
الدكتور احمد هو الاخر من مرضى القلب
الذين يقيمون في بريطانيا منذ عام 82 ياسف
على تغير حال القطاع الصحي في البلاد
كمريض قلب مباشره
ويقطعوا كل شيء وبياخذوني لجوه وبيحطوني
فاما الناس الثانيين يا حرام عما ينتظروا
كتير ساعات وساعات
هذه ليست المره الاولى التي يضرب فيها
هؤلاء الاطباء لكن فتره الاضراب الطويله
ستتسبب في تاخير مواعيد المرضى الذين
يعانون بالاساس من لوائح انتظار عليها
اكثر من سبعه ملايين مريض من لندن عروب
عبد الحق العربيه
اعلنت كوريا الشماليه عن تعهدها بمتابعه
تطوير المشاريع الفضائيه بمناسبه اليوم
العالمي لانطلاق اول رحله بشريه الى
الفضاء وذلك وسط مخاوف من اطلاقها المحتمل
لقمر صناعي هدفه التجسس العسكري كوريا
الشماليه اعلنت ايضا استعدادها الثابت
لتحويل نفسها الى قوه فضائيه عالميه مؤكده
انها تحرز تقدما متتاليا في تطوير مشاريع
الفضاء وفق معاها معاهده الفضاء الخارجي
نقعد بكم مشاهدينا الى لندن والاضرابات من
القطاع الصحي والتي تحدثنا عنها قبل قليل
معنى مراسل العربيه مصطفى زارو مصطفى
راينا في التقرير لزميله عروب تداعيات
بالفعل بدات تطال المراجعين والمرضى حدثنا
اكثر عن هذه التداعيات اثر الاضرابات في
القطاع الصحي
بحسب خدمات الصحه الوطنيه تم تاجيل اكثر
من 350 الف موعد
بسبب هذا الاضراب الذي يمتد لاربعه ايام
وسينتهي صباح السبت
يعني في الساعه السابعه صباحا هذا سيكون
له اثر سلبي وايضا يهدد سلامه المرضى بحسب
تصريح لوزير الصحه امس عندما سئل عن عدم
الجلوس مع نقابه الاطباء للتفاوض بشان رفع
اجورهم وقال بان وضع شروط كهذه بنسبه يعني
رفع
الرواتب بنسبه 35% لا لا يتماشى مع
الزيادات والتسويات التي تمت بين وزاره
الصحه وايضا المضربين خاصه فيما يتعلق
بالمسعفين والممرضين هذا بالاضافه انه
يريد تعليق هذا الاضراب قبل الج لوس
المفاضله ولكن يبدو ان
يعني هناك تصعيد من قبل الطرفين ولا مؤشر
على نهايه مما يدل على ان هذه الازمه
ستستمر ربما لاسابيع اذا مصطفى يعني هل من
ربما خطه للحكومه لاحتواء هذه الازمه يعني
راينا المحتجين يتحدثون بانهم يخرجون من
الاجتماعات ومن المفاوضات بلا نتيجه
الطرفان متمسكان
بشروطهما ولكن بالطبع من يدفع الثمن في
اخر المطاف وهو
عامه الناس والمرضى الذين تم تاجيل
مواعيدهم بالاضافه الى ان سيكون هناك مزاج
سلبي في قطاع في قطاع الصحه وخاصه وان هذا
النقص
للاطباء في المستشفيات سيكون له اثر سلبي
على زملائهم وان كان مثلا بالنسبه للاطباء
الاستشاريين يعني
يوافقون على هذا الاضراب ولكن كم من كم من
من يوم سيتم تحمل هذا الضغط الهائل الذي
تعاني تعاني منه خدمات الصحه الوطنيه
وخاصه وان هناك ما يقارب من او اكثر من
سبعه ملايين شخص ينتظرون موعد في في مختلف
في المستشفيات في
المتحده وهذا الاضراب يعني يجب الاشاره
بانه فقط في انجلترا نعم مصطفى يعني لماذا
يتمسكون المحتجون بهذا الاسلوب للاحتجاج
والاضراب يعني هل سابقا اتت اكلها يعني هل
تمكنوا من اخذ ما يريدون من الحكومه بهذه
الطريقه
يعني
اذا ما عدنا الى التسويات التي عقدت في
السابق يعني كانت يعني في حدود سته في
المئه بالاضافه الى دفع الى لهؤلاء
المضربين ولكن بالنسبه للاطباء يقولون بان
منذ 15 عاما لم يتم رفع الاجور
يتماشى مع نسبه التضخم وخلال هذه المده
حقيقه بان رواتبهم تراجعت يعني فعليا او
قيمتها تراجعت بنسبه يعني 26% وبالتالي هم
يطالبون برفع هذه الاجور بنسبه
55% مما سيكلف دافع دافع الضرائب يعني ما
يقارب من مليارين جنيه استرليني ويقول
وزير الصحابي بان لا يمكن يعني تحمل هذه
الاعداد الاضافيه لهؤلاء ولا يتماشى مع
التسويات التي عقدت عقدت مع الاطراف
الاخرى شكرا لك من لندن مراسل العربيه
مصطفى زارو
من القصر العباسي الى عموم احياء بغداد
قصه او قصه لعبه جاءت عن طريق الصدفه
لتتحول فيما بعد الى طقس من اهم الطقوس
بعد الافطار التي يحرص البغداديون على
ممارستها بوجود اطباق الحلويات والحان
المربعات البغداديه
[موسيقى]
هنا في قلب بغداد مدينه الكاظميه ذات
الطابع الديني والتراثي في ان واحد بدا
جاسم الاسود ممارسه لعبه المحيبس التراثيه
كلاعب يافع في احيائها وازقتها العتيقه
يصبح فيما بعد ملك هذه اللعبه لثلاثه عقود
اللعبه تتلخص في اخفاء خاتم بيد شخص واحد
من الجالسين الذين يتراوح عددهم بنحو مئه
شخص ومن ينجح في اظهار الخاتم يفوز بنقطه
على خصمه انا ميثاق بطولتي يعني
والفضل تقريبا العدد كانت 500 بخمس مئه
يعني كان قبل عدد مفتوح ماكو بطولات رسميه
هسه صارت على النظام دوري وتصفيات كان قبل
يلبسون اي شيء سويناه زي موحد زي العربي
تراثنا الدشداشه وخليناه قانون ونظام
لا يوجد تاريخ دقيق للعبه ونشاتها لكن احد
ابطال المحيس يقول انها تعود الى العصر
العباسي وان اللعبه جاءت عن طريق الصدفه
الوقت تاريخي اللي صار به صار الخليفه
العباسي اتصور الخليفه العباسي ضاع منه
خاتم بوقتها
فراد يعرف المحبس وين جماع الحاشيه مالته
فاراد يعرف المحبس وين شافه فراسته انه
اكو واحد وجهه اصفر فلذلك كشف المحبس وهي
كانت هاي الحادثه بشهر رمضان لذلك ارتبطت
هاي الحادثه بشهر رمضان
انتشار لعبه المحيبس وتزايد شعبيتها
وانتشارها في بغداد والمحافظات اخرجها من
المناطق الشعبيه الى القاعات الرياضيه
الكبرى لاستيعاب العدد الكبير من اللاعبين
والجمهور هي لعبه تراثنا يعني اجدادنا
واجداد اجدادنا يلعبون هاي اللعبه
يعتبرونها تعلوله بعد بعد الفطور يعني
يتونسون ويلعبون
لعبه المحيبس تحولت من لعبه تراثيه الى
طقس من اهم الطقوس بعد الافطار والتي يحرص
البغداديون على ممارستها لوجود اطباق
الحلوى وعلى انغام المربعات البغداديه
سامر الكبيسي العربيه بغداد
يواصلوا مسلسل منه ولدنا اثنين كسبه ثقه
المشاهد السعودي والخليجيه على حد سواء
اتصدرت مشاهدات المسلسل والنقاشات حول
قصته مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي المزيد في
فقره كواليس مع سهى الوعل واعداد ايهم
القاسم
[موسيقى]
مو عيب اننا نطيح يلا يا ولد نزل الشنطه
هلالنا واخيرا القصه التي لا تشبه كل
القصص
[موسيقى]
يعني اتجه الى منحنى مختلف تماما عن الجزء
الاول وبيكون واضح بالنسبه للمشاهد الجزء
الاول ممكن كان التركيز اكثر شي على
الكوميديا بينما الجزء الثاني لا تفرع
وراح اتجاه النصر الى عده امور ولكن ما
تخلوه من الكوميديه الكوميديه موجوده ولكن
المستوى الدرامي اصبح اكثر من الكوميديا
ولكن بطريقه لطيفه وخفيفه على المشاهد
المسلسل تصنيفات شاهد استطاع انه يحترم
مركز الرابع في السعوديه من ناحيه ارقام
المشاهده اسهم في ذلك بحسب راي النقاط
توقيت عرضه مباشره بعد مسلسل طاش في
الفتره الذهبيه يعني هو نجاح الموسم الاول
حملنا مسؤوليه كبيره كان نجاح كبير وعظيم
والحمد لله رب العالمين يعني
وصلنا فيه لمناطق كنا حابينها وصلنا لها
فالجزء هذا احنا في مسؤوليه علينا لازم
نكون نقدم افضل
من الجزء الاول فالجزء الثاني في مفاجات
حلوه في احداث جميله في تنوع شخصيات تنوع
احداث فلكم جدا جميله بصراحه عائله وحده
ولا الشركه قاعد نقدمها جدا جميل الحمد
لله تغير وتركتر بيني كريان وبين الاستاذ
عند محمد كان جميل جدا ليش للريان موسم
الاول كان قاسي معها تماما الين صار الدرس
اللي هو رجع العالم الفقر ثم رجع المكان
الحقيقي
مع بعض التغريدات من هنا وهناك
[موسيقى]
احنا حبيناك عشانك انت
انا حبيتك عشانك انت لا تغير نفسك عشاني
[موسيقى]
في ختام النشر نذكر بالعناوين
التسريبات الامريكيه تكشف المزيد صربيا
رفضت فرض عقوبات على روسيا وبيون تلاعبت
بالصواريخ
بعد ضمان تقدمها في بخموت شرق اوكرانيا
روسيا تجز نبض الغربي باطلاق صاروخ
باليستي متقدم وعبر للقارات
الصين تصعد ضد تايوان وتخطط لفرض منطقه
حظر طيران شمال الجزيره لثلاثه ايام خلال
شهر ابريل الجاري
بريطانيا تكشف تسلل جواسيس الصينيين عبر
جنسيه ثالثه وتخشى تسلل الجواسيس الروس
عبر الوسيله ذاتها
في امان الله
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات